[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're discussing magic and whether or
not this powerful force of nature can
ever be stripped away from those who
wield it in the World of Harry Potter
where magic is omnipresent and omnip
potent I can't help but wonder whether
the extraordinary abilities possessed by
witches and wizards
can ever be lost typically witches and
wizards who are destined to wield magic
begin exhibiting signs of magical
ability in childhood though within this
time frame there is considerable variety
for instance individuals such as
Professor mcgonagle exhibited clear
indications of magic from an early age
in her earliest moments she demonstrated
remarkable abilities playing her
father's bag pipes summoning toys to her
crib and even exerting in control over
the household cat similarly Ariana
dumbledor showcased her magical prowess
during her early childhood conversely
individuals like Neville Longbottom took
a longer time to manifest their magical
abilities although he too exhibited
magic in his earliest hours by
discreetly manipulating his blanket for
added security this subtle act went
unnoticed Neville did not demonstrate
magic again until a more pressing
situation forced it out of him it
occurred when he was dropped from a
height and fortuitously bounced
resulting in his rescue from a
potentially Dreadful fall overall
however it's agreed that magic is
displayed at a minimum by the time the
witch or wizard reaches 11 years old
otherwise known as Hogwart AG but I
wonder can magic be stripped away just
as quickly as it manifests can one who
finds themselves accustomed to their
magical capabilities be then reduced to
what is effectively a squib
today we're going to discuss witches and
wizards losing magic in Harry Potter we
will also touch upon instances of losing
magic in other fictional works such as
the concept of severing in Robert
Jordan's Wheel of Time or the magic loss
depicted in love Grossman The Magicians
hopefully by drawing comparisons to
these fictional universes We Can Shed
light on whether similar occurrences
exist in JK Rawlings own creation
origins of magic before we can dive too
far into the top topc of whether magic
can be stripped away I think it's first
important to take a look at what magic
actually is and where it comes from in
essence magic is an inherent part of the
fabric of the universe and exists as a
kind of energy that can be harnessed and
manipulated by those with the ability to
do so those possessing the appropriate
genetic makeup this theory is supported
by the fact that magic is present in
various forms in the natural world such
as in the plants and animals that
inhabit the The Wizarding World
furthermore it appears that magic is
somehow linked to the human psyche
presenting itself as a manifestation of
the power of the mind this theory is
supported by the fact that many magical
spells and incantations in the series
involve the use of intention and
visualization as well as the power of
belief witches Wizards and other
creatures who possess magical abilities
bear a gene that allows them to exploit
the natural forces of magic this is
reinforced fored by JK Rowling the
ability for humans to use magic is a
hereditary trait passed down from a
person's ancestors which allows witches
and wizards to practice it rather than
being a mystical or unnatural Pursuit
that defied the laws of nature however
magic simply allowed those who could
wield it to exploit them in very
specific and creative ways that muggle
Sciences were unable to replicate in
essence witch's Wizards are essentially
Advanced or mutated human beings that
have either inherited the ability to
exploit magic through their ancestry or
in rarer occasions independently
developed the ability to exploit magic
through a genetic mutation they have
advanced physiologies heightened
perception and if trained enough have
the ability to control the world's
elements to some extent it would also
appear that besides possessing the
magical Gene witches and wizards have
some other notable physiological
benefits that could classify them as
advanced humans these traits include
longer lifespans though not to a
significant extent and a resistance to
most common illnesses basically witches
and wizards are just enhanced humans
which means that their existence pre
magic is the same as the original
ancestors of humans who were thought to
have first existed about 6 million years
ago over millions of years humans
developed and evolved and so it
shouldn't be surprising to anyone that
eventually humans started showing
Supernatural capability
the ability to perform magic losing
magic in many other movies series books
there's always at least a tiny mention
of draining a Wizard's power dry for
example in The Wheel of Time series
magic users known as channelers can be
sered from the one power permanently
cutting them off from their ability to
channel in CS Lewis's naria series
individuals who possess magical
abilities can lose them if they become
disconnected from aan the great lion who
over sees nania in Lev Grossman's The
Magician's Trilogy individuals can lose
their magical abilities in response to
things like emotional trauma or
intentional magical interventions in
Christopher pini's inheritance cycle
magic uses called spellcasters can lose
their magical powers if they overuse or
exhaust their energy known as their
strength and in the Enchanted Forest
Chronicles magical individuals can lose
their powers if they willingly renounce
or reject their magical abilities so I
can't imagine the Harry Potter Universe
being any sort of exception to this rule
as it happens there is a quote from
Dumbledore in the Half Blood Prince
alluding to this very subject of course
it is also possible that her unrequited
love and the attendant despair sap her
of her powers that can happen and from
this one tiny Standalone quote I think
we can reasonably derive that yes it is
possible for one to lose their magical
powers
this quote referring to merapi gaunt
implies that strong negative emotions
such as heartbreak and despair have the
potential to affect a witch or Wizard's
connection to and control over their
magic it also highlights the intricate
relationship between emotions and magic
in the Harry Potter Universe suggesting
that emotional well-being and stability
can influence a person's magical
potential and abilities this is very
similar to Lev Grossman's The Magicians
where magical abil abilities can be lost
in response to emotional trauma but
something important to remember here is
that the magic still isn't drained and
that's because it never existed within
the body in the first place it is not a
resource within the body but rather a
ubiquitous pervasive force that exists
all around us the same magic that
surrounds witches and wizards also
surrounds Muggles the only difference is
that Wizards have seemingly developed a
way to harness it but now that we've
established that it is possible for a
witch or wizard to lose their magical
abilities I do want to dig a Little
Deeper unfortunately Beyond Dumbledore's
quote there is nothing else in the books
pointing to how one might lose their
powers however there do seem to be a few
other instances that come to mind when
attempting to consider how one may lose
their magical powers magical diseases
just as diseases in the Muggle world can
erode our Essence leaving us as mere
shells of our former selves it is
reasonable to believe that the Magical
World of Harry Potter also Harbors
afflictions that have the potential to
strip witches and wizards of the very
essence that defines them magic itself
one such disease that comes to mind is
the maledictus curse a dark bloodline
perpetuated curse that is passed on
through generations of family members
and is transferred from mother to
daughter a maledictus suffers a blood
mal addiction a type of curse that
causes the sufferer to slowly transform
into an animal over the course of their
life the animal can vary according to
the specific curse in Harry Potter the
main maledictus that comes to mind is
Nini whose blood malediction meant that
she was destined to turn into a snake
becoming less human and more Snake each
and every day in earlier life the
maledictus will possess the ability to
transform at will but that's what slips
over time eventually you will lose the
ability to transform and will be stuck
in whatever animal animal form that is
destined for you as fans of Fantastic
Beasts will have witnessed nagini was
once a woman able to perform all sorts
of magic at will but from the moment she
became trapped in her snake prison she
completely lost the ability to harness
magic in this way while she was still a
magic individual Nini no longer
possessed the ability to wield the
Natural Forces around her I'd also wager
that in addition to the maledictus curse
there are probably other magical
illnesses and conditions that can cause
a gradual or sudden loss of magical
abilities if you can think of some
examples be sure to comment them below
magical draining Dementors are
malevolent spectral beings that feed on
human happiness leaving their victims in
a state of despair and hopelessness when
a dor is near it exudes an overwhelming
sense of coldness and darkness
effectively sucking out the positive
emotions of those in close proximity and
if you're unlucky enough you may be
subject to the dementus kiss a
devastating attack which removes a
person's soul from their body leaving
them as an empty shell alive but devoid
of their Inner Essence the individuals
who experience the dementus kiss are
often characterized as being left in a
state of irretrievable absence they are
effectively rendered into a vegetative
condition devoid of any willpower or
personal identity additionally as you
might have guessed those subjected to
the kiss also suffer the loss of their
magical abilities one law no discussion
surrounding wi or Wizard's ability to
perform magic is complete without a
lesson in wand law according to WAND law
a witch or Wizard's connection with
their wand is essential for harnessing
and channeling their magic effectively
if a wand is broken or if there is a
misalignment between a witch or Wizard's
magical core and their wand it can
result in a significant decrease in
their magical abilities while this may
not imply a complete loss of magic it
does suggest that external factors can
impede an individual's ability to
harness their magic and it does
highlight the extremely temperamental
nature of the witch or Wizard's
relationship to Magic science versus
Supernatural before we close out this
video there is one other aspect of magic
that needs to be clarified it's pretty
widely accepted that magic in the Harry
Potter series is based on science a
natural force that can be studied and
understood through the study of magical
Theory and the practice of magic
reinforcing this is the fact that the
use of magic in this series often
involves scientific principles such as
the conservation of energy however there
is a subset of people that believe magic
in the series to be a product of
religion a mysterious and unknowable
force that is beyond the understanding
of mere mortals in fact this religious
correlation is one of the main reasons
that the Harry Potter books became temp
temporarily one of the most banned books
to have ever hit shelves under the
assumption that the Magic in the books
was religious in nature many Christian
groups strongly opposed it the reason
for this being that witchcraft is
directly denounced in the Bible but I'm
here to set the record straight magic is
science-based a fact that has been
confirmed by JK Rowling herself I only
bring this up because the origin of
magic is going to influence one's
interpretation on how said magic can be
lost and that about sums up today's
topic hopefully this video has provided
you with some clarity on how a witch or
wizard can lose their magical abilities
though this thought had occurred to me
in the past I never took the time to
research it so this has been quite a
fulfilling video to make also if I've
missed anything please comment it down
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live